I love black mirror but some of the
episodes freaked me out because they're
so dark were you surprised by how funny
this was I was I was I was like grateful
and surprised because I'm a giant giant
baby when it comes to especially
existential dread which I feel like you
know these episodes are like steeped in
all the time
um so when I saw that this was I mean
it's still a mind-bending episode that's
hard to fully comprehend but it does
have such
um a pulse of Comedy throughout and then
you throw Salma Hayek into the mix who's
so funny we had such a great time well I
know she's a fan because I just watched
her on Good Morning America and she said
she fell in love with you while working
on this show
I'll take it I can die happy
okay I honestly want you guys to do a
movie together or another show like I
need some sort of buddy cop thing going
on I kid you not we have been we wrapped
and then went up to Charlie Brooker
right away and we were like so if you're
interested in writing a buddy comedy for
us we would be open to it and he did not
seem that that's something that he
wanted to do but um if anyone else out
there is open to a buddy comedy with me
and Salma Hayek please we're begging you
I love it if you posted that you
wouldn't be surprised if the Creator
Charlie Brooker came out and said you've
been pumped are you still surprised that
you're in an episode of Black Mirror
extremely extremely like I just it just
it's a show that I've I've Loved from
afar for such a long time and it really
feels to me like kind of the upper
echelon of TV these days and Charlie
brooker's brain is so bent and
fascinating and cool and so to even know
that I was on his radar was like a
hurdle to get over and then to get the
job and then to work with Salma and it
was just it's I still feel like it could
be all a Dream well
um a part that I love so much and it's
it's not like a huge part but it's so
memorable is your scene with Michael
Sarah
you guys are so good she was had you
worked with have you met him before like
had you worked with him no no I like
tried to say hi to him at a music
festival one time and it didn't go very
well and and then I got to actually work
with him and uh he's so smart he came in
for rehearsals completely off book and
he has a huge chunk of information that
he needs to get out
um yeah and he came in off books so
professional so kind and it was only two
two days that we got to work with him
but but man he left a he left an amazing
impression so I get really excited for
new episodes of Black Mirror but I also
get a little terrified because
emotionally sometimes I can't handle the
twists and turns do you feel that way
about Black Mirror Kate oh yeah yes
there are certain episodes that I
definitely either had to just walk away
from watching for yeah or um yeah pause
but also so I'm such a huge fan of the
show so it is exciting to be a part of
it Josh have you always been a fan I've
always been a fan since the very
beginning
um I I was working with Rory Kinnear the
first episode came out and he told me to
watch it and he played the PM in that
first episode so that's like the iconic
episode
I know well I mean they're all this is
the thing about this show like everybody
has their own favorite and it's it's
they're all iconic in their own way like
I love San Junipero and like yeah how
much you like the Bryce Dallas Hardware
one we forget the name of and like
everybody's got their own favorite
episode
um it's that's what's amazing about the
fact that Charlie is able to create all
these different things and we've only
seen ours Kate and I haven't seen the
other four from this season yet so I'm
just excited as a fan to go back and
watch
the other four of this tomorrow actually
amazing okay so listen the episodes are
good but there is always one or two each
season that stick with you in this
episode sticks with you I honestly keep
thinking about it Josh did you feel that
way when you're reading the script like
what stood out to you about this episode
well I thought the potential for it to
become one of those sort of like like
for it to become an iconic version of
Black Mirror was really high I mean not
just because of the script which was
phenomenal but the fact that Kate and
Aaron and John Crowley were involved as
well they were all involved well before
I was I wasn't the I literally wasn't
given the script until a week before
they were about to shoot so I keep
asking who was cast before me as David
and Kate hasn't told me yet so I don't
know hey tell us tell us Kate
hello it was my sister
good answer that's a safe answer amazing
see one of them
speaking with you and
you and Pauline your scenes are so good
they're intimate they're intense what
was it like working with him so not
intense it was so lovely and nice yeah
such a such a refreshing thing when
you're dealing with such you know
difficult emotions
um yeah we had such a great time and we
filmed in the most well if you see it in
the episode the house that we filmed in
was so gorgeous and it was in the middle
of uh Kent
um hours away from London
yeah it was just a really great
experience the crew was incredible Josh
are you excited or nervous for your
family to see you in this episode well I
don't think my my wife already told me
she's not gonna watch it oh really yeah
no because she asked me what it was
about when I read it right off the bat
and I was like well yeah there might be
some kids that get murdered and she was
like no I won't be watching that
she can't like she can't separate
herself from the entertainment that
she's watching right now on like a
visual row level so I I get that I
totally understand it uh but a big fan
eventually she'll watch it and then
she'll be mad at me because like yeah
because you're just so good in this
the thing that I love so much about
Black Mirror is there's always twists
and turns but this episode in particular
has
such a Twist that I did not see coming I
just want to know exactly how
challenging has it been to talk about
this episode without spoiling anything
it actually has been very I think it's
been challenging you've definitely been
dancing around it all day
um but
um yeah I think it is worth the effort
uh uh but yeah I think it's I think it's
a Twist that what's fun I do think Black
Mirror is full of twists and turns but I
think this type of twist will even shock
Black Mirror fans which is fun and cool
that we can even shock the
um
um yeah fans of a show as depraved as
this so I love that uh Claire you were
so good in this what did you love about
this episode I
just think it's so shocking and um I
mean we've all been talking about how
getting the opportunity to be a part of
something like black mirror that we all
love and adore and respect and and it's
such an influential machine is there's
such credibility that comes with that
and and just really excited to dive into
to the the concept of of um celebrity
culture and commoditizing people and um
how brutal that is but also how you know
it's it's the moral compass is is
wavering from all aspects of it and I
think that it invites a lot of
discussion hopefully
um
onto the subject yeah absolutely Danny
is it true that you tweeted out you
would do an episode of Black Mirror for
free so you manifested this yeah it uh
it is true I I saw the leak of season
six and I just tweeted it just on a whim
um and it turns out that during that
same time they're having conversations
over at Netflix uh I was already in the
conversations but they just didn't think
that I'd be able to do it because of Top
Gun press yeah
um and the Tweet basically verified to
them that I would absolutely do it which
it to me like hearing the story the
first time around I was like that's
crazy you guys were considering like not
offering it to me because you thought I
wouldn't do it which is just like I love
the series so much um so being able to
be a part of it I think was is just it's
either manifested or it was already in
the works and it just kind of unlocked I
don't know but it just it feels good to
be a part of Charlie's Universe
um I love that that's so cool but you're
so good in this as well this whole
episode is so strong as I see you're
obviously playing a member of the The
Paparazzi Lady Gaga sings a song called
Paparazzi I'm sure everyone's been
asking you but what has been your
favorite part about working with Lady
Gaga on the set of the new Joker film
fortunately I cannot divulge anything at
all
um but I think there are a lot of smart
people working on this and I think
um that is what I think
I love that that's good that's safe
thanks so much guys great job